You've looked at the behavior of f of x equals 4 over x minus 1, around x
equals 1, right in the middle of the graph. But what's the behavior doing far,
far to the left, and far, far to the right? It doesn't look like any other
curve we've seen before in the course. Which of these statements right here
probably describes the behavior of this function, as we move far, far away from
the y axis? Does the curve approach the line y equals o, the x axis, from above
but never touch it, as x goes either to positive infinity, or negative
infinity? Does the curve approach y equals 0 from above but not touch it, as x
goes to infinity. And does it approach y equals 0 from below as x goes to
negative infinity? Does the curve approach Y equals 0 from below, as x goes to
positive infinity, and from above as x goes to negative infinity? Or does the
curve approach Y equals 0 from below, as x goes to positive infinity and to
negative infinity?